[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back welcome back just one
utterance of my voice can vaporize a
human yes
uh dummy victim the black bolt of the
brick room the burbank black bolts as
they sometimes call him they call me the
burbank black beauty
welcome back to the break room the new
rock stars live show coming to you
live from our actual new rock stories
break room here at new rockstars hq in
uh beautiful burbank california or in
burbank california all right
i mentioned every episode but it's as of
yet unconfirmed uh
coming up today uh we have some behind
the scenes photos from black adam we've
got a lot of star wars news and of
course we're going to be diving deeper
into that she-hulk trailer that we got
yesterday that shield trailer dropping
right before the break room yesterday is
the reason you got to watch the break
room every day right you know you never
know
the latest breaking news that literally
dropped right before we were we were
starting you think we're not going to
cover it of course we're going to cut of
course we're going to cover it we're
going to cover it immediately and in
fact if you uh wonderful uh viewers if
you have some thoughts on that trailer
some questions throw those into the chat
we'll do a big q a at the end if we
don't get to uh if we don't happen to
bring up whatever you're asking we'll
try to answer it at the end and speaking
of viewers we got our reverse swear jar
going today um and
reverse swear jar because every time we
hit a hundred dollars we are allowed to
curse that's right give me one minute
real quick to the camera
you were a little stingy yesterday
we got one swear word out and in this
economy that's not enough the world's a
difficult place we need to get our
curses out so dig deep in those pockets
and find a way to give because i got an
f in me today i got an s in me i got a
j-o i got a q
i got a i got an exclamation point i got
a swear word you've never even heard of
what exclamation has a queue
yeah well i don't find it too deep
you know yeah swear flation is real uh
under under biden's economy we can
barely afford to curse once um but let's
begin this episode as we do every day
with some headlines everybody oh that's
right okay well
who didn't put that in the script
looks like i got a little trigger happy
with my hands that's all right that's
right of course i'm zach cuddleston and
i'm joined uh as i often am by my good
friends here we got mr brandon barrett
oh hello we got the wonderful jessica
clemons
and we got uh the burbank black bolt uh
tommy bechdel charmed i'm sure what
mouth
it's more like what a mouth on mr
bechtel what'd that mouth do hey baby
headlines okay um at the disney up
friends yesterday which um is when we
got that great shield trailer but we
also got kevin feige revealing that loki
was the most watched uh marvel disney
plus series to date that's kind of
something we assume that's certainly our
coverage of that show was super popular
our on our channel absolutely he also
added it's the first series to get a
confirmed season two with production set
to begin in a few weeks so loki season
two maybe coming soon we love that and
i'm not really surprised by that news
given how popular loki was as a movie
character you're offering basically what
is essentially
two movies worth of loki as a standalone
series i think it makes sense to me i
was very surprised but that's because i
am a wanda ride or die and wandavision
was the only like mcu disney plus thing
that my mom was actively like did you
watch it did you watch it because they
got a lot of people that don't normally
watch my mom was like that too she's
like do i need to watch one division i'm
like it'll make no sense to you
well and maybe one division just
suffered a little bit by being the first
yeah you know so maybe they're just more
subscribers of disney plus by the time
loki rolls and quite a heady concept yes
you know um yeah great and and speaking
of loki season two the entire cast
supposedly will be returning uh and
we're crossing our fingers even kang
kang jonathan majors um the woman the
actress whose name i'm forgetting right
now who played uh rinsland uh rin player
and i was gonna say the loki variant uh
yeah goo goo and and um sylvie whoever
plays silvia yes i almost had sylvia
plath i was like
will be reprising her role and and uh
loki gator uh hopefully alligator loki i
like here loki i'll say kid loki too kid
loki um also oh what's his name the
actor the wonderful british actor
richard richard oh my god where richard
kind of spins we're crushing them that's
exactly what i know you guys know leave
it in the chat yes help us help you
reject grant richard richard richard
don't forget to eat nothing like a dick
grant whatever i might say the entire
cast we were returning
i don't know if they mean like the deep
rocks probably the courthouse
mr wilson
i think that was the big question people
were like zone wilson going to do two
seasons of this show i get the feeling
that he really enjoyed working on that
there's something about the way he the
press
he seems like kind of a mercurial guy
and in the past like he doesn't really
like rave about his project he seemed
like many other actors we find when they
get into the mcu obviously you know the
money's not bad but
they genuinely enjoy the work i'm sure
tom hiddleston seems like he's a fun
game to work with you know he had more
fun on loki or marley and me oh
what about the one with j-lo i think he
had a great time oh yeah marry me oh man
harry man part of the marley me
cinematic universe that's my partner
we're hoping here especially at new rock
stars we're hoping for uh the voice of
miss minutes tara strong yes from the
channel friend of the channel she's
appeared on uh a rick splained episode
that tommy co hosted right and you can
go back and watch me stammer as i try
and ask her questions i'm like miss
strong very nice to meet you yes um and
according speaking of tara strong who's
a frequent uh voice on rick and morty
according to variety rick and morty the
anime has officially been handed a
series order by adult swim and hbo max
uh and
you know we've kind of gotten those rick
and morty like anime like commercials
and even kind of clips but like they're
basically they're gonna give it a full
season it's gonna be 10 episodes of rick
and morty anime um overseen by takashi
sano who is the director of those um
rick and morty anime shorts that got
released in the past
that's cool kind of unexpected i think
we're still getting a normal rick and
morty season here well will this count
as that bulk of the
freaking orders that they got complete
all i know is if we don't do another
season ever explained i don't get my
free bluetooth so
please come back rick and morty you can
actually get a free bluetooth views
promo code rogue yeah youtube.com
uh we got a new behind-the-scenes photo
of black adam via the rock's instagram
yeah throw that up there
ooh i wish i could see it there oh black
and white gray scale kind of something
in between his legs we'll never know
we'll never know actually
oh
yeah slow still slow trickle of uh
of of information we're still waiting on
a trailer for black adam we're expecting
that movie it's like a tried yesterday
q4 thing we're getting that i think it's
in
november we're getting black adam so
hopefully we get a trailer maybe in the
next month or two sometime this summer
it got pretty but it got pushed right
but it's still 20 22. yeah but i got
pushed a little bit yes that may be
waiting for like what because didn't
they get pushed because of the effects
yeah so it probably they're probably
waiting to do a little bit more for the
trailer
yes yeah apparently uh those special
effects still a little backlogged from
pandemic and a rush to get out all that
production but we're excited for black
adam uh
things we're also excited about things
are revving up for mad max furiosa
the kind of prequel from uh director
george miller gave an interview in
deadline which he called the prequel a
saga
i mean mad max fury road is a pretty
saga
it's all still in the same universe too
right so it's just adding to like the
saga yeah this is the beginning this is
the beginning but i'm wondering are
there any
furiosa films to tell well this is anna
eight i always say her name on your
taylor joy anya taylor joy playing the
charlize
charlie's role so if it i would assume
it well maybe it wouldn't actually i
guess it would be her up until charlize
theron's part kind of like the prequels
of the star wars movies have shown us
you can do as many people as you can
squeeze in just keep fitting them in
there yeah you know what how about an
immortan show
well you know sadly that actor has
passed away but they could do prequel
style and they could recast
already mediocre
according to a press release uh that
came out as part of the uh disney
upfronts um she-hulk has had its episode
count reduced from ten to nine now this
is not that big of a deal i think marvel
has pulled this move multiple times i
think the one division episode count
went up you thought it was going to be
six and it went to like eight or
something like that went down one day
yeah nobody just went up two right did
they add that sounds right and you know
some of that is they are
you know shooting these as kind of like
giant movies and then kind of chopping
them up yeah i'm sure it's an editorial
decision not like uh we didn't like how
it was going to read with audiences so
we slashed the last step that's so nice
that they can literally just be like
there's a lot in here but we don't want
to take it out let's make another
episode yeah we're gonna make another
episode um and finally on she-hulk which
we're going to be coming back to here in
a moment ben dick wong confirmed to
appear in shihok which now that we've
seen his buddy abomination in the
trailer makes a lot of sense and we saw
them in shanghai together too yes so
they're probably just best i also think
friends if you have a marvel property
coming out just say benedict once hey i
love him
i love him he keeps his schedule open
he's always game dj's on set we learned
is that he did that interview i think
with kimmel where he was they were
talking about how he was like the onset
dj he also makes a lot of tick tocks
with uh zochetta oh yeah
yeah cute french they're very cute
speaking of cute it's my segment yeah
all
right
we're ready for the break room breakdown
play my graphics
play my graphic today eric vaughn it's
coming out today right i always ask i
always ask it's already out it's already
out it's already out it's already out uh
we're breaking down eric vaz's she-hulk
trailer reaction video that popped up on
our channel yesterday uh let's go ahead
and take a little little peek a little
peeky
now we still do not know exactly why
bruce was shown in human form with his
arm and a sling in that shang chi post
credit scene especially now that he's
back in hulk for him with his arm
completely healed kevin feige told
screenwrite that that sling was
intentional and i have theorized that
maybe hulk depowered a human form to
allow himself to give a life-saving
transfusion to jen but the imax aspect
ratio of that chongqipo's credit scene
showed banner was also on this other arm
wearing a piece of wrist tech with a
glowing green piece to it which now
after doctor strange and the multiverse
madness has come out kind of reminds us
of those 838 cuff links that were
powered by the green sand of nisanti
those saiyans de-powering the wearer for
a certain amount of time maybe wong gave
banner that cuff to de-power him so that
they could temporarily heal his arm when
he was in human form because as hulk his
flesh is otherwise so impenetrable they
couldn't really do anything to him
okay okay so we see a lot of it's it
definitely isn't continuity error right
definitely all planned as feige said so
we see
i want to talk first we see bruce with
the device on his arm right and by the
way tommy had to step away to get um
de-powered so he'll be he'll be back we
had to sprinkle some sands of vashanti
yeah
sprinkle some stands on him uh do we do
we think that he's found a new way to
activate the sands
it just seems weird i i don't know how
the sands work i don't know i don't know
i didn't i took it in the in the film
that they like kind of negate magical
powers
uh you know because
i want to see dr strange's magical
powers and then you know i don't know
how america's chavez's powers are
defined within the mcu but it must be
some form of magic or cosmic energy no
they they were did were they used on
yeah she was in the in the the one of
the cells too i think she but she she
punched her way out oh she did punch she
did punch her way out yeah i don't know
well i i guess her powers well they are
different things they use the t on her
yeah but like anybody can be drugged
right anybody can be drunk don't quote
me
but you can't really drug the hulk
because the hulk will get stronger if
you try and drug him
sure well i i was gonna say
i think i i
i like eric's idea though i will say
like don't you think bruce banner might
have come up with something that can
de-power himself that's what i think i'm
more on that than i am on the sands i
don't think it's the sands i think it's
something else that he created for
himself also why is he only where this
could be on a time kind of spectrum but
he's only wearing it on chongqi it
didn't look like he was wearing it in
the
it's a cooling time go ahead baby didn't
look like he was wearing it during
she-hulk right
yeah and we only see we don't see mark
ruffalo we only see hulk
in hulk form smart hulk form in we also
don't know and this is the problem with
the the mcu
time still being at so far ahead of our
time we don't know where things fit yeah
right so shang chi could still take
place later than
uh
yeah we see wong and abomination uh and
we see that the portal they go through
the same room but maybe that's because
of the events of she-hulk that leads oh
so that's why long working with
abominations do you think that's why his
arm is broken well maybe in this show he
learns how to de-power yeah
i was gonna say eric eric's theory is
that they
turned him into bruce banner to heal his
arm because as hulk they wouldn't be
able to heal his arm which
to me rings false wouldn't his his
healing properties his ability to
regenerate tissue whatever be better in
hulk form than in a de-powered human
form unless like somehow he's immune to
like magical healing you know back to
tank-esque right kind of thing they said
he's his skin even injured is so hard to
penetrate yeah yes because like he's in
the an end game when they're doing the
time travel stuff we see that hulk smart
hulk is wearing the swing like hulk is
damaged which is like a very rare thing
it doesn't really happen in the comics
like he the body his body will evolve to
find ways to heal and survive and all
that right so maybe it has something to
do with the gamma radiation that's
released from the stones
as hulk his body can't do it i don't
know i i do like the idea though that
there was no way to get blood out of him
as honk so he had to get down to it
to like get the blood out to save
jessica and while he's there he's like
jennifer oh my
maybe he has to stay in a hotel and
there's not a bed big enough for hulk
he's like well i gotta i gotta come down
to bruce
air travel's rough yeah do we think that
bruce will end the show as smart hulk or
do we think bruce will figure i like
your idea that shanxu's later so he's
finding he's probably like stuck right
now for a little bit and he's just like
hulk ugh smart hulk i don't think he
likes being bruce it's the best of both
he gets recognized
and like nobody can sneak up on you and
he can jump really far yes he dabs he
dabs not like that he does he does oh my
gosh i
stop it and scroll down on this prompter
so stop it and scroll down on this damn
prompter oh this dang prompter um
so okay so we think that he i okay i'm
writing the coattails that i think that
this is taking place before shanxi so i
think that's why he has all the
mechanical stuff on his arms i do not
think it's the sands uh because why
would bruce banner use the sands i don't
know i just think he would come up with
his own contraption to make it just as
zack said and we i
don't i do agree that he does like being
smart hulk are we referring to bruce and
hulk together now with smart hulk is
that what we're calling i think it's the
easy way to just
glasses as like a professor hulk or
something yeah yeah i think so
because most of the other hulks yeah in
the comics right
like abomination and she-hulk like
they're able to be normal and talk
normally and have their cognitive
reasoning and essentially the the person
they were before is still there with
bruce and hulk it's like it's all it's
like a personality thing where in the
comics they've established that like
hulk and bruce are two separate
personalities it's like a dis
disassociative identity disorder thing
right hulk is like the gamified hate
that he has inside of him for his own
dad
and stuff yeah no i have a question
sorry as as we all noticed i was forced
to leave you were geopowering i was
being deposed
by the uh
burbank police
you're always hinting at these weird
crimes
it's the black bolt of burbank or i uh
maybe i'm a lead witness
maybe i'm
solving a crime today anyway did we talk
about the fact that maybe there's a link
between a de-powered abomination and a
de-powered hulk maybe they both needed
to be de-powered for some reason yeah
did we do was that discussion no we
didn't talk about that no and and
definitely like as eric pointed out that
kind of red striped cell which we see uh
tim tim roth yeah right the d-powered
abomination neil blonsky maybe and and
you know though wasn't it in a very
similar cell i guess there's multiple
cells in the trailer because the crazy
razor blade cell is a different thing
that's right
that's probably at the banner compound
versus the red stripe thing is probably
at this prison complex but i guess i
mean maybe they need
medical answers from a de-powered
abomination and a de-powered hulk maybe
potentially something to needed to save
jessica i don't know why you guys keep
saying jessica jennifer jennifer sorry
i'm following you're following him also
the chad said
lord savior uh
body of christ do we think bruce will
end the show as smart hulk form 65 of
you guys said yes 34 said no i
disagree with you guys oh you're saying
no i'm gonna say no i think it's gonna
be just bruce banner i think it's gonna
be bruce banner but from this show all i
know is that um it's a lot about
jennifer and it's also
very horn
it's a lot of jessica and a lot of
horniness reminder that
we will answer any questions you have in
the chat about she-hulk and just make
sure you put them in the chat is this
producer john because i love being on
camera and this is very far away the um
the the pull out of smart hulk form so
everyone actually agrees oh out of smart
should stop homes this part because i
can't read thank you john so you guys
agree with me yeah we'll have to rewatch
the trailer again closely if you're in
that chat keep this open but pop up the
trailer another window is is emil
blonsky wearing some sort of device in
his cell because i love this idea that
cause that's something from the comics
that abomination doesn't switch back and
forth he's just abomination
because i think he's just got an eye
watch with a with a board ape as yeah
there's the screen oh okay he's just
checking out the crashing price of his
he's like no my board ape with a fedora
and a spliff
it's only worth 113 dollars now
that's how you de-power a hulk is via
the blockchain hey let's go around real
quick um what what news or revelation
would depower you from your gamma
radiated self ah okay it calms me down
like well it's just like just like
ruining me
okay okay okay
um
for me it's coming back to where i
parked
and seeing a parking ticket oh i got one
the other day
for me it's
turning on espn at 11 30 at night and
see it
josh allen arrested outside of a
nightclub in miami florida for being too
hot
for being too strong
for me it's when i come into work and
tommy disregards my outfit and doesn't
say he looks cute what was the first
thing i said to you today when i saw it
you said something else first
yeah what would do it i'm gonna say
first thing i said to you was damn
jessica you look beautiful today it took
too long
it was the first thing i saw
for me it's when i go to buy mouthwash
and they don't have the non-alcoholic
version i have to buy them i'll call it
it's hard on my gun
[Music]
i changed mine mine is when uh i wake up
to my wife heidi klum and she says
this has been too much sex i need a
break
wait okay you're disregarding the entire
family
okay uh it's a hat on the hat by this
point uh so thank you again keep
throwing those uh she-hulk questions in
the super chat and let's uh thank some
folks that are helping us bring this
episode to you today uh our our good
friends our delicious uh snack making
friends at baksu ooh
baksu uh is a monthly subscription
service that delivers premium japanese
snacks and tea pairings straight from
japan to your door we got something
delivered to our door each baku features
a new theme providing a gourmet journey
through japan every month and we got the
tanjubi box uh the same one we were
snacking on yesterday and this is like
the birthday box tanjubi means birthday
in japanese and it's celebrating baksu's
sixth birthday as a company happy
tanjubi box yes and so um they picked
through some of the like fan favorite
and staff favorite snacks tommy and i
both got nasty with some savory snacks
earlier i got that tokayaki take corn
puffs oh that octopus in corn puff form
i mean that's all i need it wasn't and
octopus
corn puff might not sound great to you
but it was delicious it was amazing i'll
give you my initial reaction because i
thought i was eating something else
because i read the booklet wrong so i
went oh
wow
he did i heard it i heard that from you
i have a groaning smile yeah
that's how you call that
there are some other things we call the
vector
but and i add the potato snack curry
flavor which is a delightful translation
of probably what's a much more
interesting japanese name that was great
like these are these are snacks that are
like have some properties similar to
things we eat in north america but then
they're wildly interesting and different
as well and this great booklet that
comes with every uh baksu kind of gives
you a little history tells you what
region of the country makes them uh may
happens to be asian heritage month so
it's a perfect time to highlight baksu's
collaborations with authentic family
businesses and snack makers throughout
japan
again you get a little history sometimes
on their on their website they'll do
interviews with the like 100 year old
people that have been making these very
specific snacks for a long time to try
boxer yourself and support us here at
the break room as part of new rockstars
click the link in the description and
use code rockstars to get 15 off your
order that's right all right
and then um jessica do you want to show
off what is keeping your can nice
[Music]
i always keep my cans cool
we've got these uh uh great they're
called soup cans i believe um but soup
is in superheroes
um
oh my god tommy loves it
these are available over at the epic
hero shop uh our good merch partner
friends over at epic hero shop get these
and they have a whole summer collection
that uh eric just talked about on the
channel yesterday grab grab yourself
some of those take it to a barbecue or a
summer party so these are called soup
cans like a superhero as opposed to my
favorite superhero chowder man
there is a superhero
s-o-u-p oh okay thank you for spelling
that out it's time for mandatory fun no
no
boom oh
boy
that's right it's time for mandatory fun
the segment's so nice we play the
graphic
hit it again
was too ready
he's keeping that trigger
crime if we didn't play it for a third
time hit it again
and the audience is chanting more and
more and more because we want four hit
it again oh my god come on
he's rebound
john he won't stop until you do it
[Applause]
broken you're breaking the man i don't
have a lot going for him these days john
just play the game again
again you're killing him john all right
oh thank god there it is
there it is the only way i stay alive is
if we hit it on number five here's it
again
you're done
oh god oh okay oh and i must be feeling
sick cause we're gonna
[Music]
philanthropist and world-class lover
tommy beckham forces his three best
friends to have fun with him whoever
wrote that is really really cool you
wrote it tommy
[Laughter]
i don't know i haven't been to work in
three days today's all about reboots
remakes reimaginings revivals
all words
that start with r
anyway
great observation
i did say genius
anyway i thought today we'd take a
moment
to uh plead with the media gods to bring
back some of our favorite film
franchises that maybe didn't get their
due when they launched you know i'm
talking
movies that were one-and-dones that were
establishing whole new worlds of
adventure and
and excitement so i asked each one of
you to uh defend or or plead for a
franchise's revival uh would anyone like
to go first or would you like me to
oh appeal well i'll bet lead off here
sure and now um
uh stop me at any point if i grossly
misunderstood the premise or sanctuary
fun well we do like to keep things tight
here absolutely uh so tight we got to
play it nine
there you go
we might have skipped a couple numbers
don't play it you did you
heard it again
a little uh uh a much loved but little
scene film from 2012. okay i want to
reboot continue reimagine whatever
the series dread
okay i don't know if you saw the 2012
dread starring carl urban and lena heady
[Music]
it was excellent it like was at the peak
of like 3d madness in film it was one of
those movies that was really shot with
3d in mind there's like a crazy there's
like a drug that everybody takes that
has like cool like spatial effects it's
gritty i mean the the dread series is
the super long running or it's part of
like the 2099 uh or thing i'm i'm
butchering the the number but like a
super long-running australian comic book
series that like is su is very expansive
has all kinds of characters we got a
really terrible sylvester stallone uh
from schneider joint in the 90s wow and
then this great great uh carl urban you
are dread
and you know what that movie is great
you should go watch that movie it didn't
it didn't quite take off it didn't make
enough money for them to continue the
franchise but we deserve it carl urban's
still out there billy butcher himself
yeah okay he'll do it right you can get
that cast together grab that director
let's do cutting down soups
uh
i have i got to find for you from the
first uh stanley la comic-con back when
it was called something else
uh kamikaze con which they for some
reason
somewhere in my archives in the bechtel
archives i'll find that bring it in for
you zach thank you my little gift to you
because that's just what we do here on
mandatory fun hit my graphic again
at the dead silent time bring it in
[Laughter]
jim henson studios
walt disney corporation
hbo max i believe owns the rights
currently
the dark crystal has been done wrong oh
okay
okay we got a no that's my fault i lean
into the table
chronically overweight
take it off camera
jim henson studios ghost of jim henson
dark crystal wonderful movie came out in
1982 took years to make brilliant
puppeteers the mother of yoda i'm
forgetting her name the woman who
finally perfected the yoda puppet that
had was forced into obscurity for years
because everything had to be cgi and is
now making a comeback
we got that movie a couple years ago you
dropped a netflix series on us and i
really enjoyed the netflix series it was
a little confusing it was a little
expansive maybe you went a little too
wide
narrow the scope
bring us back to the world where the
gelflings are just emerging how the
crystal has been restored
jen has
done his air jordan spike put the
crystal back in
let the gelfings repopulate show me the
gelflings making love as puppets show me
a pregnant girlfriend giving a painful
breach birth and almost dying only to be
saved by a pod doctor
this is don navi what's happening over
here
this is my time
brian henson
i know you're looking you know you're
watching this show come on the show you
count i know you got the bag of my blood
i sent you
now it's time to return the favor and
not in blood form
in felt form
give me a dark crystal
that shows a live birth
place
what is the dummy what is the tommy bike
told blood transfusion give you that the
bruce banner button to the trees
uh herpes uh
and hpv
i'm basically all of them
okay
that's all i'm saying let's do dark
crystal the right way puppets coming out
of puppets for [ __ ] oh my gosh you
can't say that word yet for [ __ ]
and uh fried dough disgrace yeah
i did see a show at bob baker's
marionette theater for all you la stands
where there was a bird puppet marionette
puppet they pulled an egg out of it the
egg hatched and a bird pumping bird
comes out of the eggs
all controlled by one person the
technology's there the sciences we have
the technology
to do a livestream
maybe it's not for netflix maybe it's
for my streaming service slime
oh no oh
no
coming to all your major roku's apple
tvs and slings this is not fun this year
i don't want to follow this the
streaming service that nickelodeon said
no
all right jessica what do you got i
have a good one
i love the dark crystal um you do
obviously i just i i know we don't need
to go we don't know you go back to it um
you know what i would love to see they
don't even need to reboot it just keep
it going um series of unfortunate events
so a series of unfortunate events was
not only the only book i read on repeat
and the magic treehouse as a child but
we all loved the jim carrey one and i
was so happy to see neil patrick harris
come back for the netflix version that
got renewed for a fourth season but
stopped at the third
which pissed me off they did the third
or they did they did the third and they
didn't finish the fourth yeah this is my
nephew off too he was very upset i was
very upset the series of unfortunate i
might be a a looney tune but the series
of unfortunate event is one of the best
series as a child it was dark and it was
great and i think this can open the door
for more craziness and even if you did
want to make it dark kind of like the
dark crystal it's like as a child yeah
you watch the 80s one you're like this
is fun watch the netflix one you're like
i don't know where we're going you're
like this is confusing you can do that
kind of stuff with a series of
unfortunate events and make it just for
people that are my age uh or you can
make it for also kids too but i think
we need to keep it going we should have
kept it going even if it was for just
people like me
um i would love for a series of
unfortunate events come back netflix
head i know that you spent a million
dollars on stranger things you didn't
need to do that you could put it towards
serious unfortunate events it's very
easy
move it over move it over that's a good
thing let me help you here for a second
get us both in four please
snicket
lemony i know you got my baby toe i see
you
your baby returns a favor what live
birth
never mind never mind never mind
your
[Laughter]
this little piggy went to the market
this little piggy went i wonder why
you've been pulling to the left when you
walk on yeah got a weird gate now i want
to talk about a franchise that could
have been okay we're talking a move one
movie to launch it they were ready
disney was ready for this they had
tie-ins with mcdonald's for the toys
they had uh plans at their parks they
had characters walking around a live
show it was everywhere
everywhere okay this movie
won oscars oscar-winning film okay and
they cancelled the whole plans i'm
talking about 1990s dick tracy okay they
need to continue dick tracy warren
beatty's still got the rights he'll be
dick tracy d.a jim i don't care whoa but
let's get to it
all right get on your wrist radios and
calling dick tracy okay look it up on
youtube you can find the show they used
to do it disney where would dick tracy
was great they were ready madonna was
there now dustin hoffman was there
pacino's there we know mandy patinkin
mandy patinkin still out there he's
still out game game maybe he loves this
channel mandy if you're watching
i know you got that
sack of hair i sing
come on this show your challenge didn't
come from the top of my head
rainbow stephen sondheim wrote the songs
for dick tracy if you haven't watched
chick tracy go watch dick tracy it is
it's
worth a watch just for how wild it's
crazy it is is it available streaming or
have they buried i believe so it's
definitely available it's out there okay
um interesting now would you want it
rebooted in the same way they did it in
the 90s i want that i want you to make
it like a comic book i want the six
primary colors i want it all baby okay
don't modernize it at all it should the
show should be an older dick tracy
passing on the torch to his son junior
who he adopts in the first film spoiler
alert and they named him dick tracy also
let's do it someone in the there's a
bunch of chat pics but one that's not on
there that i saw in the chat that i just
want to shout out someone said the mask
and if you want to bring back the mask
baby
and i mean
there were some great great ones in the
chat uh ryze and the guardians yeah yeah
i love that tomorrowland which as a
disney standard i actually joined that
that was a that was a cool idea john
carter pretty good last starfighter i
mean that's a favorite as a kid for me
beetlejuice fields got the animated
stuff yeah yeah mr mr meaty saying the
last airbender that's a very popular
common one i think they are re rebooting
i thought that there was talking avatar
the last airbender i believe they're
doing the live-action one on netflix
small soldiers they mean with the little
action
soldiers
archer
yes like our emissary of the gorgon oh
aragon 100 persons got
i stopped listening to april when she
moved away from christian music okay
classic uh
uh well tommy who do you think who do
you think won that one uh you know it's
never easy for me to say so i
unfortunately had to invite a friend of
mine to oh
where's my bird
we don't know where the bird is
perseus
go number four on tommy the bird's gone
i think
where's my bird thank you oh wait i
think it's flying
[Applause]
no
perseus no
i need to stick my hand up inside you oh
god come in see a live version here it
comes he might go i know you got the the
bag of hair i sent you i i i did get
that bag of hair i'm sorry it's in my
hair pile i gotta autograph it and send
it back gotcha a lot of fans want
autographed hair these days some of the
dress stamped air yes
i just sniffed the hair and i
immediately like a homing pigeon know
where it came from oh god all of these
pleas for revivals struck my
heartstrings
but in the end
don't we all just want a little more
dick oh boy yeah thank you tracy yeah
you bet green lit kid thank you get out
there and make that film thank you or my
name isn't t michael bechtel we gotta
pry the rights out of warren beatty's
hands and then we can make that move
back to the earlier episodes of the
break room yeah the real ones the day
one's recognizing fans know who i am
day 14 fans
good to meet you
uh reuben meme did have a super chat i
want a spawn reboot so bad i love me
for a sometimes
yeah yeah that spawn reboot was on i
mean it was on my [ __ ] door
oh
boy thank you everybody
i was watching it i was watching it i
was waiting for a dog to say 170. thank
you everybody for contributing to the
super chat there we hit on your buck so
uh we head to curse and tommy uh ever
the eagles oh someone said the reboot
the dark tower tower right right that
one will probably get remade no matter
what
i feel i have taken more time that's
enough that's a nice from you
mandatory
uh we do we should chat about all this
star wars news that also came out
yesterday during these upfronts
uh we'll talk about some of these
headlines that i'm talking about a
little bit there was a big vanity fair
article revealed that uh taika watiti's
star wars film could be the next one to
hit theaters ahead of rogue squadron
which is patty jenkins film uh in an
interview last summer watisi said he
hoped star wars would be his follow-up
project after he wrapped thor love and
thunder it sounds like that's what it's
going to be a lot of this news was like
moving around star wars projects yeah
but it's weird because the way that
rogue squadron was reported
i felt like it was like on the verge of
just being dead like as a movie now
they're like it's still slated to come
out in 2023 there's no way but they
haven't started photography on any of
these we don't think so
fast for star wars i don't know and
there's also like you know we've gotta
be like johnson's getting a trilogy that
got pushed back right which we may never
see and a big theme uh from the news
yesterday was like we're done with the
skywalker saga which i think is great
get away introduce some new characters
tell some new stories absolutely uh stop
digitally adding people to the movies uh
let's let's get some new stories in
there
another headline from yesterday was that
ewan mcgregor confirmed mary elizabeth
weinsted's casting in the upcoming
ahsoka series uh and is that uh that
that's scott pilgrim
yes yes
yes along with uh you and
yeah and if if you read the trades out
there you might know that uh ewan is
married to mary elizabeth weinstein uh
so i don't know how he figured it out uh
i don't know how he broke that nose
why didn't you get her into uh obi-wan
ah you don't you know that's mine yeah
yeah yeah you don't go off you don't dip
your pen in the company eek you know
what i mean okay maybe ewan's really
hitting the the the not healthy snacks
at the crowd
he doesn't need her in his ear just like
the lord nachos you in its second meal
yeah yeah i've been working
all day
we also got more info on the disney plus
star wars series the acolyte uh show
runner leslie hedland described this
series as a mystery thriller set in a
prosperous
and un seemingly peaceful era so it's
confirmed that the series gonna be set
roughly a hundred years before the
events of the phantom menace which i
really like is that so that would that
be the earliest star wars scene
portrayed on this
on a screen obviously there's the game
the popular game knights of the old
republic which goes way back there's
been tons of uh comic books and uh uh
expanded universe novels portrayed in a
film or a disneyland series this has
been i've never seen anything maybe
we'll see a little uh darth plagia
running wise
yeah maybe i don't know uh but yeah
that'll be really cool to see especially
because that's the time when the high
republic started falling so it should be
pretty interesting i'm excited to just
get away from the stuff we know yeah
really show me some some stuff in the
star
wars another thing from that vanity fair
interview with kathleen kennedy uh she
explained how they now recognize that
recasting main characters from the
original trilogy trilogy has not worked
out as well as they hoped so it looks
like we'll be doing more de-aged luke
kind of things yeah rather than like
casting someone to play a young girl oh
okay can you give me an example of when
it didn't work there's been a big fan
push well i think just she means it
didn't work out right like i don't
really know a star wars story yes
i was thinking because i immediately
went to um sebastian stan is luke
skywalker no no the ones that did work
really well which is childish gambino oh
sure that's what glover is that's
something we were kind of talking about
around the office is like donald
glover's supposed to be
orlando
lando or running this lando series we
don't know if it's supposed to be
youngland or old lando because they
brought back to orlando but
i don't know if this means it's still
happening he did an interview with jimmy
kimmel a month or two ago when he was
promoting atlanta where he said like
yeah i'm very excited about being lando
i would like to keep doing it but did it
sounds like all these other star wars
projects where
it's not shooting i i don't know what's
gonna happen i don't know could could
die and maybe it started and maybe what
kathleen said doesn't include what
they've already done yeah maybe they
just mean we're not going to do it
anymore yeah so i was just going to say
i love your phrasing of new new lando or
old lando now as
old lando that's that's what about 30
minutes outside of kissimmee yeah that's
right
that's the i5 corridor
right off the bat
i think though i do think in that
interview and specifically with that
comment it kind of struck me as the type
of thing that was kind of
said almost flippantly like
yeah like we're acknowledging that solo
wasn't like a huge success critically i
still made a lot of money right i'm sure
it's probably another one of those
movies that kids loved and we'll find
out in like 10 years that there's
we we're talking about like franchises i
loved where that movie was going at the
end with darth maul
[Applause]
and i don't know that anybody's problem
with that movie was in the portrayals of
these characters there was a lot going
on behind the scenes the directors
and least favorite star wars movies
because i don't think we're ready to
fight
the champion
uh so also in this interview uh kennedy
stated that the success of the star wars
tv shows has reshaped their filmmaking
progress with uh most of the upcoming
films scheduled to be made
being stand-alone films rather than
trilogies so again they're kind of done
with these children i mean they really
wrote a blank check when they were like
we're releasing a star wars movie every
year oh boy and then they started doing
it and everyone was like we don't want
this yeah no no one asked for this but
the tv shows have been successful and i
like what they're doing the tv shows and
i'm excited for more stories that are
further away from the stuff we know sure
yes yeah yeah um let's let's go to the
chat and see what folks have to say want
to shout out uh frequent uh super
chatter our friend john ayton could
bruce have been testing the device to
see if it would work before giving it to
abomination by testing it on himself i
think it would do it the other way
around i tested on abominations
feels bad maybe he feels like a little
guilt or maybe he feels like
you know he he might feel guilty because
i mean emil got kind of screwed over by
thunderbolt right yeah right thunderbolt
ross didn't tell him what the hulk was
and emilio was just following orders he
gave him a little bit of juice he's like
go out there you'll you'll get him
before he turns in the hulk he'll be
fine yep uh gets his back broken needs
more juice yeah yeah yeah and so i i do
kind of feel a little bad for him yeah
he's following orders uh kyle bird uh
threw us a couple bucks saying play the
graphic hell yeah
there it is just for you kyle bird let's
go um uh ltlt smash saying uh throwing
some love in the pile hope you get a
swear soon we did thank you um i just
had a thought
what if
abomination is suing the hulk for
damages oh and he has hired the services
and jennifer has to
defend her own cousin yeah i mean that's
an interesting thing because he was
following the orders of a general now he
was
uh special he was sis right he was a
british soldier which but there's always
a lot of confusion right because peggy
carter was a british soldier working for
american soldiers right so i don't know
that's a good point though maybe he is
suing the department of defense for
allowing thunderbolt ross to do this yes
but you know we test a lot of stuff on
our soldiers in the real world so
which is sad and depressing but
does he have a legal leg to stand on
that's interesting well and we have to
assume right jennifer walters works for
a law firm so she will be defending
clients right she won't be a prosecutor
right so like and and they even say
we're gonna um you know focus on
superhero matters so that that's gonna
be fun i wonder if the equivalent of her
across the aisle right like if there's
going to be a special prosecutor
prosecuting superhero yeah it does seem
like she's working for the government
right like the department of justice or
something well
it's like if you're defending you know
uh superheroes that are under captivity
or whatever right you have to go visit
them in prison or and they want to make
her the face of it so i think she's
probably working for the government like
she's not our own law firm but they
start to provide the defense counsel
like you said so
that would be interesting cody mills
said zach's dab and jessica's beauty
gives me purpose
i guess tommy and i can leave
no
zach is on camera saying you can drug
anybody oh yeah
i mean i'm not advocating for it i don't
think that's a good thing to do but it's
factually accurate am i right abraham uh
i said live-action thundercats
thundercats great question if you ever
seen a cat give birth oh my god
stop talking about live births that you
want to witness
listen puppets cats it's spring time
yeah okay the season of renewal my
thoughts go to being a father uh uh gaz
man had an interesting question i guess
i've never really thought about this
before why does smark hulk smart hulk
wear glasses oh because
gaz is assuming that when he's powered
up right like his vision would
automatically improve
we don't know that it has a direct
effect on his like
vision well right we would have to or
like the hulk hulk will fix what's wrong
with this this is also still this is
still smart hulk so it's still half
bruce half hole right right maybe his
eyes had changed yeah like i mean his
arm was like broken so it's like yeah
his facial dimensions are slightly
different as smart hulk right yeah like
don't look a little bit more ruffle in
the face he's not he's not throwing his
brows it should be addressed the fact of
like oh everything else gets healed but
your eyesight but i get i don't know
we'll talk about it does he join
for production
makes him look smarter as all glass
wearers know um wouldn't uh wouldn't
mind seeing a film based on kashyyyk or
just a story on the wookies
it's called the star wars holiday
special which you can see on our channel
brilliantly broken down by me
in one of two bootleg breakdowns the
smash hit series that was so nice we did
it twice and then never again if you can
find a bootleg breakdown on our channel
hit that like button for me
do all the time myself right you know if
we see a big bump of traffic on those uh
a year and a half later maybe that's the
series that's a series that needs to
read back speaking of reboots tommy beck
told him
i know you got that cup of peanut butter
you're talking to yourself yeah
stop mailing yourself pete that doesn't
matter it doesn't copy right yeah does
that mean it's copyrighted
sean bell has a good idea for a she-hulk
the leader could we see a cameo from tim
nelson inside the cube that is a a
strand that i'm sure kevin feige has on
his his big board of loose end yes that
he's just waiting to bring that back for
folks that remember back in the ed
norton uh
incredible incredible hulk right like
tim blake nelson the great actor from uh
oh brother where art thou and in
addition to a number of films played
like a scientist working on the formula
he gets his drips on his head his head
starts expanding he starts expanding in
gross ways and he smiles right yeah
he did not sport the uh very sharp
mustache at the very box
but there's always time and i think in
one of the like comic books that's
supposed to be about the mcu they imply
that natasha went and got him and
brought him back to like shield hq but
again i don't know how much of those
comic books they're sticking to because
in agents of shield
they inferred that like abomination was
on ice in a in a holding cell somewhere
like not in temple like nelson or not in
uh emil blonsky form but it still has
abomination they just kind of froze them
because they don't know what to do with
them well i i do think like depending on
how legal this this series gets right it
could be an interesting thing of like if
abomination is accused of crimes
but you can turn him back into a meal
block
are you
can you be held accountable for your
gamma radiated self wow you are no
longer gamma radiated didn't hulk eat a
person or am i thinking of a different
thing is that is that from
eating a person i don't remember a whole
game we could we could veto a person
could definitely be
speaking of spiritually similar to venom
we thank you all for watching today
uh we hope that yes eddie we thank you
all for watching you don't need anybody
certainly that doesn't want to be eaten
that's right you know what i'm saying
dog okay uh because these dogs are
hungry
oh lord give a duck a bone leave a dog
alone okay um nothing but the dog in me
okay um
we thank you all for joining us as you
have uh every day well the dog days are
over here
um brother for sale he's only 50
we'll be back tomorrow with more songs
from your childhood as well as uh friday
which
there's been whispers that friday will
be drinking on air wow
do you think this is a little underneath
where it works
zach's been whispering to himself we're
drinking all right we're drinking booze
i'm saying booze uh there'll be
something else in these soup cans uh so
if again if if you enjoy how one hinges
gets show up on friday if you don't
enjoy helen hinch we are well you
probably quit watching about 40 minutes
yeah although based on the metrics we've
only gone up so hey
uh thank you all for watching uh see you
tomorrow bye
ah
[Music]
you